hello
uh welcome to this talk i'm luis lopez
i'm a software engineer at the national
snow and ice data center uh thanks for
pi data for organizing this event
under this circumstances uh
and thanks to nsidc for locating some
resources for this talk
um we're going to talk a little bit
about what the basic of climate change
and some of the
remote sensing data that is useful for
scientists
so they can get a better understanding
of this phenomena but it's uh so
important
for everybody to know and understand
a little bit about the data center we
are
based in boulder colorado and we're part
of the university of colorado boulder
and also with part of a bigger uh
organization called sears
which also gets funding from different
sources but the main
the main uh uh source of funding for us
is the national science foundation in
nasa
and we're one of the 12 data centers
that
um stores and distributes the nasa the
nasa uh
air observing system data sets so all
the satellites that nasa has
uh in our processes and the distributor
are
separated kind of by the type of
missions and we distribute data
uh they're related to the
cryosphere so that's what we do we also
do field research
uh where scientists go to the frozen
regions of the world to install
some instruments they uh they also
publish papers
and they do science in general and
so we're going to talk about why
uh climate change is important what
climate change is very briefly
you probably have seen this graph before
this is the
atmospheric carbon dioxide and this is
almost a million years
and there are a lot of you know
people that doesn't believe in uh
science
that don't believe in science that are
like claiming oh but the planet was
warm before and well this is one of the
best ways that we have
uh for measuring that and this is from
ice course
uh the analysis of of this many years
um and it wasn't that hot the variation
has been between
180 and 250 to for
almost a million years and now it's it's
through the roof uh and the main driver
of that
uh jeff sax is an economist from harvard
now working at colombia there are
institutes as
it's all about scale we've really been
successful a suspicious in the last
couple hundred years in this industrial
revolution
and we modified the planet um
there is this term called the
anthropocene that a lot of scientists
think
we're living in that we're uh modifying
the environment
uh to that point that uh
well if there is anthropologists or uh
archaeologists and
millionaires from now they'll find
evidence of our existence
in how the planet behave these years
uh and one of the consequences of this
is that we have more
natural disasters every year so the
things that happen one in a thousand
years are
happening way more often uh one of the
examples this year has
been the uh fires the wildfires in
colorado and california
and this is fine but not really no no
it's not fine
um so climate change is a complex
problem it's not
you know oh well just measure the
temperature in the ocean and that's it
uh well there are a lot of system at
play systems that play in uh
in the planet and even for simple system
interaction between simple systems are
complex
like this lawrence attractor shows so
now it's killing that
it's it's way more complex but the good
thing is that
scientists are are figuring out uh these
processes
um with the help of data and algorithms
recently
so what they need in order to do this is
have good
historic records and good algorithms
so i'm going a little bit fast in this
part because uh you as i said
probably are aware of uh most of these
concepts
and i want to dive into the actual
python analysis in the jupiter notebooks
this is talking about the open science
revolution like why that is important
in the analysis of scientific data
and well the main thing is that uh you
can have access to
research and the data that was used to
do that research and that you can
replicate the results to advance your
science
in this case for climate change we're
going to talk about remote sensing
so this is kind of this is timeline
for what remote sensing is
and it's uh well it's really very recent
that we started to do this kind of
measurements
if if you go uh well
a thousand years ago the only thing that
were recorded
and that was important for the
agriculture was probably precipitation
and temperature
and that gives you an idea of very
uh well and i'm talking about active
recording because of course we have
indirect ways of measuring how the
planet behave in
uh and years are like in millions of
years
and as the high score records uh
show in the first in the first slide so
but remote sensing it's
it's a recent thing so what it's remote
sensing
uh well it's a process of monitoring uh
physical characteristics of the planet
uh in this physical characteristics can
be taken from satellites or airplane
but basically they're like passive or
remote sensing
uh instruments that will
result in a data set that
well gives you multiple characteristics
like temperature chemical compensation
topography
and other uh derived uh measurements so
these are some of the satellites that
are
being used some of these are
decommissioned some of
the new ones are not there and this is
just from nasa of course
japan the european union they have their
own constellation of of satellites
working taking different kind of
measurements
uh so what happens once the satellite
uh this is when the interesting part
starts for data analysis once that they
take this data the instrument send it to
where well then they are encoded in a
data
structure and that can be raster vector
point cloud and dimensional
uh you see two examples on the right uh
on the top is a raster on the bottom is
uh
well it's a raster but it represents a
lidar data
from another mission and the common
thing between
all the remote sensing is that you're
talking about physical measurements
with a geolocation and resolution so
that's what remote sensing data is and
these are different levels of
data processing like when the satellite
takes the instrument
uh takes the the measurement and and
it's very raw
then it's like the analogy could be in a
camera when you take a photo in raw mode
and you have a correspondence
correlation
almost one to one between the zeros and
one and what the sensor did
and then the image that has compression
that has other processing things
and finally if we keep extending the
analogy then you can apply filters to
the image so
uh that would be the same for remote
sensing uh and science usually starts in
level one
b uh not in level zero
so um once it also once that the data is
uh
project or greeted into a uh
into a projection well we need to be
aware of these uh other things that
uh will cause uh some caveats when you
are
analyzing it which is the distortion
that produces so you have to
work in the right projection for the
data and in our case
uh that we're working a lot with polar
data this projection the classical
medicator is not very useful
so we need to work with polar
projections
so we're going to analyze a little bit
of the python
landscape with remote sensing data and
geosciences so
you probably heard about some of these
packages we
use some of them at the center to
generate
some of the data that we or process
these higher level
products that we distribute and not all
of them
we want to adopt a more cloud approach
and risk and
in recent months and it's on the route
for what's coming in the center
next uh in the next year and also
i'm going to talk about that at the end
so here are some examples of
if you look for the data in our website
you'll find a lot of uh
information and different data sets of
remote sensing data sets
uh most of them and
[Music]
so all of this data is distributed in a
format right so
we have data that can be plain text and
csv
and geo json shapefile depending on the
on the
nature of the data but the cool thing
about python and this uh
ecosystem that it supports a lot of this
format so there is a there is a
one-to-one almost one-to-one
uh relation between what format you're
working on
and what python provides to you for
analyzing just for
reading the data and start working with
it uh
this is a data set that is kind of
famous well it's uh one of the most
prominent data sets that we distribute
as the ci 610
uh and at the moment we distributed in
in binary but the thought is that we'll
have to
process it in distributed net cdf the
facts are on the left you can see the
graph that it produces if you assume all
the
um the area of coverage for
for sea ice and this is important
because it reflects
uh the status of sea ice in the pole
which is uh kind of like
one of the main measurements of how the
planet is doing in terms of
warming ice reflects light and cools
down and cools the planet
and when you don't have that that
radiation is absorbed by
the open water the open ocean and well
it's a negative feedback so
um this is a different data set this is
slider
we're going to analyze this in a jupyter
notebook in in a second
and the thought is that we are going to
try to
harness the power of python uh
for making the life of scientists easier
when
doing this kind of analysis and the
secret ingredients are
das which is a framework that allows us
to scale
horizontally if the if you hit one of
the two cases where
you don't have enough cpu power or you
don't have enough memory to fit the data
sets in
uh into your computer so then you can
use
a desk that wraps the
other libraries like uh pandas and numpy
so you can
distribute this work among different
clusters different nodes in
in a cluster and you can see at the
bottom how that work
uh it's been a scale and doing at the
same time in multiple cores
and the other um secret ingredient is
jupiter notebooks and it's widget
that we are just starting to use or we
will
have like uh a couple years using them
and
it's been amazing to have uh this
ecosystem of
uh libraries that you can use
in uh in an interactive environment like
jupiter
lab jupiter notebooks uh even in a
jupiter hub for multiple users
to do data science and we can all agree
that that's
probably the de facto for data science
no matter if it's uh
geospatial data science or different uh
different
topic one of the things that we wanted
to do or
are doing at the center is like uh
trying to make this workflow simpler for
for a scientist like they usually go and
you know
start with a coffee their day they
download the data
in from a website if the data is not
that big they
load it into a jupyter notebook but we
can start
from the jupyter notebook so we're going
to to see how that
it's going so a couple projects at nsidc
for analyzing this remote sensing data
that are directly related with
climate change is like how fast glaciers
are melting
um so yeah it's
not as simple as just going to greenland
and you can uh
start doing local measurements but there
are more efficient ways of doing it
uh doing these things um so are these
scientists right
there is a senator from texas that says
that
global uh scientific evidence doesn't
support global warming
and we'll see if that's true uh so we're
going to use landsat imagery
for doing this quick analysis landsat
it's a
mission from uh uscs and nasa that
takes uh scenes from the air basically
they take a photo of the same place and
they're
in repeated locations and they some they
overlap
so you have a very good
stack of how that particular region is
changing
so it's used for different purposes like
water management forecasting and all
that but
in this case it's used for uh driving
the velocities of glaciers so
if you see in these two time lapses you
can see the different features in the
surface
moving so you can get an idea of how
fast they are moving
not an idea a precise calculation of
that
the pi the principal investigator for
the project is alex garner at jpl and
we've been working
this project with him for like a year
now and the data set for this project
was just released a week ago
and you can ask me or email me about
that information
but this is the final product in in the
website forum
because well you have to do a website um
you see the velocities the map velocity
is the most like
of greenland here in a map you can like
go to the website and and explore it and
select
region and download the data like we
were talking about
but you can also do this in a jupyter
notebook so
you can get an idea of how that's
working
and i'm gonna share
my jupiter lab
with you um so
this is a new approach that we've been
taking at the center for
for this kind of data as i said instead
of
uh taking the scientists to a website
where they download the data we want to
uh you know use a jupyter notebook
so they can like do everything here and
in order to do that
we've been using this uh amazing widget
that it's called ipi leaflet
which lets you render a map
in the notebook and you can do kind of
like almost the same things that you
could do in a web portal but
here uh so some data visualization in
this case exploration of the data
uh this is an example of how we are
going to
or a scientist can like just drop this
circle in the map and they can like
say well uh for this circle i want to
get all the velocities here
uh and you can select the range and you
can select uh
the amount of valid pixels in each of
those
because you have clouds and different
artifacts when
when you're doing this analysis so for
example in this i
just want images that are like 80
valid or or greater uh
and from starting in 91 and ending let's
say
in 2009 so with that
you can start doing the hey can i uh see
like what how many granules are each
year and you get this timeline
uh it's really fast the the back end for
this is post gis
and on top we build and that's the
general approach at the center
to build this uh uh well i
the word you know has a now a different
meaning but microservices
uh on top of geospatial databases
like mainly postgis
for the metadata right
so then you have uh the counts for for
each year and then you see
that the files for this data set are
hosted
despite that we are collaborating with
nasa they're hosting it at
the jpl domain in aws
so down the road that allows us or will
allow the scientists
to do uh cloud
based analysis and they don't have to
download they won't have to download
this data
because it's it's big so i'm gonna
just filter some what i'm doing here is
i'm saying um
i for this example i just want this many
files
i don't really want a lot of data
because what we're doing is trying to
teach them
uh how to work with the data so you can
see the data
is for granule is not that big and it
almost instantly downloaded it
so then you can start working with the
data saying okay so this is where the
center
of the selection is uh these are the
velocities it's really fast
uh and then you can like even graph
the data uh saying well in 2001 the
the speed of that particular region was
high
and now it's decreased has decreased and
you can even
plot the uh one of the scenes from
landsat from that region say
oh what will you see the
change in uh in speed right so
that's really cool i think and this is
the first iteration that we uh
have been working on uh there is another
project that i wanted to talk to you
um and i'm gonna share a
different going back to the slides
um so
here
um well this data set what it's giving
us
is the um the speed of the glaciers
right
in in a global scale
but that's that's not everything you
also need
uh information about mass and that
brings us to another project and another
data set
that does basically that with
uh lidar data and that's called the ice
flow project
uh this project is it's cool because on
top of uh
just doing that the source for for
for generating this uh well
it's not just one satellite or one
mission but we had to uh
um come up with a way of consolidating
uh data sources from different
from different uh institutions and and
mission so space lasers
oh snap there are so many and if you
want a time series
you'll have to deal with all of them and
one of the issues that we have with this
uh
project is that the operation icebridge
which is the main the main data that we
are
covering here uh comes from nasa but
also comes from different universities
and
for sure they they thought that uh each
well
they didn't thought uh were doing
something
particularly wrong but each of this um
universities or research institution had
a particular way of
or or the instrument even had a way of
recording things
so they're in even different formats and
so if you're a data scientist scientist
it'll be very difficult for you to read
all the documentation
and start from from from the binary data
and to try to build that so what we did
with this project was to consolidate
that uh we ingested all the data from
all these missions
except isa 2 which is really huge and
it's it's a new one uh what we're going
to work with is two as well
but for the previous missions we
consolidate that
so once that you order the data you'll
be uh standardizing hdfi format which is
a
one of the uh scientific formats for
working with remote sensing data
and so we're going to
go back to the notebooks
see here
same approach we're doing uh
what would be a data tutorial uh
um all of this is open source on the
nsidc github organization we're giving
an explanation of
what we're doing the coverage of the
particular data sets from each of those
missions that we're going to serve this
our data credentials are so we can
interface with the nasa common metadata
repository
which is uh where nasa indexes all the
metadata about
the earth observing system systems
and you don't need to be a nasa employee
to
create an account but uh nasa
requires that so you could it can keep
track of
track of uh the usage of the data
and the users so i'm not going to log
into nasa because i already
downloaded the data uh
notebooks ice flow so you can see i
downloaded two granules uh this is 2.7
gigabytes
this one it's uh way smaller so it's not
a trivial
data granule and again we're going to
work a little bit with
some of the widgets that we created for
oh let me
restart the kernel and all the outputs
uh we're going to work with this uh
amazing widgets
sorry um so you can see here
um the flight paths of the mission
because the main the main uh instrument
for for this data was uh the lighter
that was
on board of of these flights that
nasa flew during several years
mainly in greenland and antarctica so
the scientists have an idea of where the
density of the data
the bread of the data leaves and they
can do their selection so
they can like draw a polygon here a
bounding box
and you see where the there is more
density of flights is where
you have uh glaciers that are speeding
faster because that's what the
scientists are interested on
knowing the physical processes that make
these glycer glaciers go fast
and you can also disable some of the
layers
so you get a better idea of what you're
trying to do
uh here and you can select
different data sets you can change the
projection go to antarctica
you see the flights we're still
generating the velocity tiles for
antarctica
so you see here uh and you can start
doing your
uh well your order
the other thing is that you don't really
need to use this if you are a python
user that knows how to talk to apis
you can uh well talk to the api
and we have this um
gonna close this widget for a second
and and you have this uh swagger
documentation of the different
data sets and how you can like access
like if you want this kind of data the
parameters that you need to do
so you can buy basically build a client
uh for this for this interface and you
pause the order
you say i want this kind of data set um
and and then you will have uh the
the order ready and it takes
depending on the size of the order you
can it can take like some minutes up to
hours depending on if you're asking for
gigabytes and gigabytes or just like a
small glacier and some megabytes
uh then you download the data and what
we're doing on top of
uh well doing this ordering here in the
notebook we're also
or trying to teach the scientists how to
work with that data once that they have
it
in their laptops in their in their
machines kind of pushing the
where it's possible with a single node
because that you don't always have
uh aws credits right so um
then you can use this these libraries
that are like uh well now in the
geospatial community for analyzing uh
the remote sensing data xray
it's amazing it's a an extension of
numpy with annotated
uh access for multi-dimensional arrays
and it does some of the things that you
probably might want to do
like if everything is in the same
projection and you stack
those data frames it will align them
and it will it provides also an api for
doing
some analysis uh inbox is another
fantastic library that i'll show here
so gonna restart and we'll
light code for a couple seconds well run
the cells
okay so here i'm saying well i want this
uh
i want this file i want to analyze this
file
and import this libraries and i'm doing
that so when i'm timing
uh the running time of these cells
thus the importing doesn't get in the
way
and the reason is uh i wanted to show
you like why
these libraries uh do kind of the same
thing but they're like a little bit
different
you need to know how to work with
different data sets
um so for example what i'm doing here is
like
we wrote a client for this api that will
give you a a
data frame so you go from very raw data
from the satellite
that i mentioned level zero to
post-process
uh hdfi that you can load into a jupyter
notebook
and you get the data frame so that's
isn't that amazing
i think it's really cool for the
scientists to don't uh start
like doing the of the data messaging
messaging and uh
and start with with a data frame right
uh one of the things that we're
doing is like doing it we're planning to
do a desk
uh implementation of this in a local
cluster local machine
uh and in the meantime we're using bikes
for
big data so it's an out of core library
uh it allows us to do these kind of
things but faster
than pandas
and you see uh the time for this uh
calculations where
49 seconds bags was 12 seconds
uh and well what this off
photon data looks like in in the big
picture and this is
uh you see the these are different
flight lines for
for the mission so the flat the plane
flew
on each of these uh lines uh firing the
altimeter the lighter instrument and
what we're seeing here is from the top
so we're seeing uh the flight lines from
us if we were uh in a satellite so this
is jacob 7 again because
we we have a lot of flight lengths in in
that
crisscross and once that you have
multiple
lines in the same place you can do
science uh calculating the difference
the elevation maps
and do a differential on the different
dates so you can see
that with for example it's like you have
the velocity with this uh
the change in volume so then you can
start or the scientists can do analysis
like mass balance
and that that concludes well
they they use mass balance for doing
forecasting of sea level rise for
example
uh uh if i
go really into the
uh map here oh
okay so i'm zooming in one of these uh
cross paths and you see uh the photo and
the individual phone being recalculated
dynamically
uh and that's that's that's really cool
uh
and this data if you want to uh plot it
or the scientists want to see where
exactly is well then you have to use
other libraries like cartopi that allows
you to put a map
in the data and uh well the boundary
here is greenland we can zoom in
but to give you an idea or it sent us an
idea of uh
in in this in this scale where data is
uh you have this car to pi library that
it's also projected
it's not using uh the regular projection
so
you have to adjust for that it's not
polaristeria
[Music]
and this is one of the other
visualizations that we do about lidar
data
so one of the cool things about the
jupiter notebooks is that you can have
this uh
amazing interactive widgets and we
decimated the data so we don't
plug the the user interface
but you see the topology of the terrain
and you can even fly with the
like if you were flying with the sensor
and seeing the change in topology
in real time and i think this is
priceless for the scientists so when
they
uh go to a particular location when they
they want to do an analysis they can do
it in 3d
you see the pattern of the instrument uh
those circular
uh swats from the top and then you can
rotate it here and you have
this 3d tool here without using
uh well one of the external
tools for visualizing 3d uh points
and so the next thing will be like
basing
based on this you can uh let's like
like i said uh do calculation like
different
uh um well
the the volume change
in in the particular in a particular pla
place for the cross paths
uh that's one of the main things um and
of course this is an incomplete thing
because uh
as i said we we need to integrate this
with the system that uh
it's their most recent which is iso 2 uh
we probably
want to have something uh like task
implemented at the center so we can do
all this
amazing stuff in a cloudy way
and there is this other project called
pangeo
that it's uh i think pushing the
boundaries of geospatial analysis
uh going uh oops
going back to the
slides just to finish
[Music]
so a lot of time here i already am over
the hour okay
so this these were some of the projects
and
uh what what is all in in terms of uh
remote sensing analysis what we are
doing now and what we want to do in the
future what will happen
in the future
all this work uh wouldn't be possible if
people really smart people that work
with me
and they're way smarter than me we're
thinking
that we can do better and we never say
uh oh we always don't this way we're
always trying to make things different
and uh well
the reason is that this is a very very
important issue
we really need to understand uh the
dynamics of climate change so we have a
better
uh forecast and we can prepare so i
think
uh i was talking about pangaea and they
are doing
just that they are pushing the
boundaries of uh
geospatial analysis and it'll be really
amazing once that
most of these data centers adopt this
approach of
uh to the extent possible that we should
uh build the system on top of the data
and
the scientists don't have to download
the data or even query the data but
do these calculations in the cloud so um
and of course being able to reproduce it
uh one of the other things that i wanted
to show you is like we always get this
uh
request for doing things that make sense
like uh standardizing the data
uh and we're working towards that to
have uh analysis ready data for all the
scientists
or close to that and python is helping
us a lot
at the data center and with that
i would say thank you thank you for
listening to this talk
if you have any questions that's my
email and that's my handle for
github and twitter so
it was a pleasure thanks to paydata for
organizing this
bye
you